[Music]
Lady Gaga goes full Wednesday jumping in
on the viral takes off Trend inspired by
Wednesday herself Jenna Ortega
[Music]
it just felt appropriate those moves
made their way to the clock app soon
after Wednesday dropped on Netflix but
in place of the cramped song Google muck
[Music]
well away everybody
[Music]
users try out the choreo to a sped up
version of Gaga's 2011 track Bloody Mary
off her Born This Way album
s
[Music]
so yeah it was only a matter of time
before a mother monster put her own spin
on it especially after the trend got the
official Wednesday Adams stamp of
approval on Twitter I love it first you
see Gaga giving herself a makeover going
off just like Wednesday but I do best
then she pulls out her best kooky spooky
outfit and gets to dancing
[Music]
it's good to be alive but Gaga's not the
only celeb trying out the wacky moves
I'm not used to people engaging with me
check out Derek Huff and fiance Haley
Erbert's version
[Music]
meanwhile Lisa Renna and her husband
Harry Hamlin put their own groovy spin
on it
[Music]
I just knew that this is probably what I
should do ask for if Wednesday fans will
get more fun dances from Jenna that's
TBD Netflix hasn't yet renewed the
series for season two correct but we do
know what Jenna wants to see should she
get back to Nevermore Academy I want her
to get more in the nitty-gritty of
things and not play things so safe
because there's a lot of lines this one
about her ah it's just saving the school
and doing whatever but for me her main
drive with the monster was kind of a
competitiveness kind of man how's this
guy doing this and why can't I so I
think I think I wanted to I want to
continue down an anti-hero stream rather
than typical hero if you know
[Music]
thank you